record high temperatures have made it a
difficult summer for many of us but it's
not just uncomfortable extreme heat
kills more people in the U.S than any
other natural event and it has a
devastating effect on the economy a
report published by the Atlantic Council
found the total economic loss from heat
was at least 100 billion dollars
annually a figure that's expected to
double by 2030. Enrique Acevedo spoke to
local officials in Miami and Seville
Spain who are working together to find
new ways to deal with the problem
warm summer weather is hardly news but
record-breaking heat is making headlines
around the world
in the Indus Valley stretching from
India to Pakistan
temperatures hit up to 122 degrees in
early May
last month the UK had its hottest week
ever with parts of England reaching over
104 degrees a first in the country's
recorded history Rising heat has also
been the theme of this American summer
in July Heatwave spoke dozens of Records
across Oregon Texas and the Carolinas at
one point more than one-third of the
country was under extreme heat warnings
on any given day we're giving
presentations to community groups we're
giving presentations with emergency
responders to train them on on heat
responses Jane Gilbert is Miami's chief
head officer a position created by a
growing number of cities to focus
resources on the risks posed by searing
heat Miami-Dade County also established
a Heat season as part of that strategy
that is declared by our mayor from May
1st to October 31st it closely aligns
with our hurricane season and what she
charged me with is elevating awareness
about extreme heat on the level that we
already do around hurricane preparedness
specifically outdoor workers that exert
a lot of energy and agricultural worker
construction worker they're the most at
risk they get dehydrated DC or faint
Giovanni has worked in construction for
over 20 years says it is not uncommon to
see co-workers faint from extreme heat
in the summertime construction workers
who compose six percent of the total
Workforce in the U.S accounted for 36
percent of all occupational heat related
deaths from 1992 to 2016. heat related
illnesses can cause damage to the brain
and other vital organs categorizing the
severity of weather events and naming
the worst events increases the
likelihood that people will prevent and
protect themselves here against
wildfires tornadoes are all examples of
that now the city of Seville here in
Spain is the first one to be doing it
with extreme heat we interviewed Seville
mayor Antonio Munoz following reports of
about 2000 heat related deaths in Spain
and Portugal during July I wanted to ask
you about this system you've implemented
to rank and name heat waves here in
Seville parakeet
why are we doing it is that a cosmetic
thing at all we're trying to prevent and
alert people on what's coming to them
but mostly it's about implementing
measures to help people adapt to higher
temperatures in addition to launching a
pilot program to name and rank heat
waves the city is changing everything
from energy and water consumption to the
materials used in new buildings to adapt
to extreme heat
this is about coexisting with the rising
temperature and adapting our way of life
how we exercise how we spend time
outside how we move around the city or
go to sightseeing there's a saying for
tourists visiting Seville us Como Los
locales do as the locals do until now
that man kicking back and enjoying life
during the summer time
but it could also be a lesson for cities
and people around the world in the face
of a changing climate
for CBS Saturday morning Enrique Acevedo
Seville Spain
nowhere is safe no it's not it was in
Palm Springs This Week shooting story
got in the car after the shoot and the
temperature the thermometer in the car
said 113 degrees everywhere I've been
Portland Oregon
Chicago Washington Virginia it is record
heat and they've never seen it it's been
a hot summer before that it has been